After all,
the Greens are a party that attaches great importance
to politically correct language.
Well,
the Green Foreign Minister,
on the other hand,
tends to stand out again and again because of stumbled linguistically
and cryptic formulations.
So it can happen that she casually declares war on Russia.
Now she has just shared her wisdom on the Gaza conflict with the world
public Why not say AB immediately cease-fire when they have seen this
suffering themselves Because to uh alleviate this suffering.
To ensure as much as possible that,
especially now in Gaza,
people can be provided with the most necessary things,
water, food.
Then it just doesn't simply help out of the impulse.
Weapons have to say silence because that is not the task of politics.
Of course,
humanitarian aid reaches the people best under bomb carpets.
It is not at all up to,
of course,
to ensure that weapons remain silent.
Ne na whose task else?
That of the military or armaments industry.
Oh man,
the woman is really nothing but embarrassment.